it may have launched with a whimper but
the 3ds has finally turned the corner
Nintendo isn't looking back you can't
count yourself among the 35 million 3ds
owners worldwide there's no better time
to join the party than 2014 there are a
handful of great-looking games coming
out soon but if you buy a 3ds now
there's already a massive selection of
readily available games to keep you
visible in 2013 alone we got Fire Emblem
awakening and unforgiving yet rewarding
strategy RPG an adorable town simulator
and Animal Crossing Donkey Kong Country
Returns from retro studios of Metroid
Prime Fame and a Legend of Zelda a link
between worlds
GameSpot's Game of the Year for 2013
there's also a little something called
Pokemon X&Y
perfect for anyone with an itch to catch
em all atlases found great success to
releasing to shin megami tensei and to
Etrian Odyssey games last year Capcom is
representing with a surprisingly great
Board of Street Fighter 4 another
charmingly entertaining Phoenix Wright
game and Monster Hunter 3 a punishing
co-op action RPG with lots of monsters
to slay and gear to collect did I forget
to mention the large selection of
downloadable classics from the Game Boy
Nintendo Entertainment System and other
old-school consoles they're cheap
bursting with nostalgia and some have
been optimized for the 30s display other
Nintendo franchises will be appearing on
a few TS soon starting with Yoshi's new
island it's derivative of passio she's
Island games but that's kind of the
point
still it builds on the existing formula
by adding new control schemes designed
for the 3ds hardware and features an
increased emphasis on secrets and hidden
collectibles Smash Brothers is also
coming in 2014
bringing characters from every corner of
the Nintendo universe together for a
fun-filled four-player slugfest and it
may even set a new standard for portable
multiplayer fighting games bravely
default flying fairy one of the most
anticipated 3ds games comes out in just
a few weeks it's a game with a confusing
name but it's cut from the same cloth as
classic Final Fantasy games like Final
Fantasy five tactics and the four euros
of life if you finally recall Final
Fantasy games of old you absolutely have
to play bravely to fall and of course
you can't talk about the 3ds without
mentioning its unique screen which
projects two video streams at different
angles for each eye allowing you to
experience 3d gaming without the need
for glasses
it's not always perfect but there are
games such as Super Mario 3d Land there
are far better experiences on a 3d
screen and they would be other ones even
with the exotic screen tech the 3ds is
still an affordable system the high-end
larger-sized 3dsxl starts at $200 the
same price as a PlayStation Vita but it
also comes with a memory card and is
often sold in bundles with limited
edition designs themed around an
included game the more portable standard
3ds is $30 less at 170 but if you want
to get a 3ds for less money and you
don't really care about 3d the slate
like 2d s is only 130 dollars and
there's one important detail that hasn't
been talked about yet the StreetPass
StreetPass is a system that lets you
passively trade avatars with other 3es
owners you only need two 3ds systems in
the same room to exchange avatars which
you can then use in various minigames
built into the operating system every 3d
s owner I know cites it is one of their
favorite features on the 3ds the
hardware may not be as powerful as a
PlayStation Vita but it's less expensive
and hardly disappointing on its own
terms
you haven't jumped on the 3ds train yet
you owe it to yourself to pick up one of
the best antenna systems of all time